RECENTLY, SEAN SAT DOWN WITH HIM
AND HIS ATTORNEY.
WATCH THIS.
>> YOU ARE THERE 72 HOURS.
THAT YOU CAME TO TAKEN THE MIC
OVER A PLATOON WHERE A BUNCH OF
TELE- BAND OF MOTORCYCLES HAD
KILLED MEMBERS OF THAT PLATOON
AND TOOK OUT THE LEADER SEVERELY
INJURING HIM.
THESE GUYS PAST THE CHECKPOINT
AND DIDN'T STOP.
SOUNDS LIKE EXACTLY WHAT HAD
HAPPENED JUST BEFORE YOU HAD
GOTTEN THERE TWO WEEKS EARLIER?
>> ABSOLUTELY, HAPPENED ALL THE
TIME OVER THERE.
>> MY
>> YY
>> YOUR JOB IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE MEN COME HOME.
HOW MANY SECONDS DID YOU HAVE TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THEY WERE
LIKE THE ONES THAT KILLED AND
INJURED THE LAST FIT PLATOON
LEADER AND KILLED OTHERS.
>> .
AND THESE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
NOT JUST THE AMERICANS ON THE
GROUND, BUT THE YOUNG
18-YEAR-OLD SOLDIERS FROM AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
ALSO THAT RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
REPUTATION OF THE UNITED STATES.
WE ARE ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE AFGHAN
FORCES.
WE ARE LOOKING AT A MILLION
DIFFERENT THINGS AND WE HAD A
COUPLE OF SECONDS TO MAKE THE
DECISION.
>> SO IT WAS A WAR AGAINST
TALIBAN.
THAT PLATOON I JUST EXPERIENCED
DEATH INJURIES BECAUSE THE GUYS
ON A MOTORCYCLE.
THEN AFTER YOUR CASE WE FOUND
OUT THAT IN FACT, EVIDENCE,
PHYSICAL DNA EVIDENCE.
RIGHT?
LITERALLY WAS ON IEDs FOR THE
VERY GUYS THAT YOU ENDED UP
RIGHTLY KILLING.
CORRECT?
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
>> THE ARMY HID THE EVIDENCE.
THEY WANTED TO PROTECT MAMA'S
RULES OF ENGAGEMENT.
THE RULES WERE SET TO PLACE THE
LIVES OF THE TALIBAN ABOVE THE
LIVES OF AMERICAN.
SO HE TOOK OUT THIS APPROACHING
MOTORCYCLE THAT THREATENED HIS
MAN.
HE FIRED WITHIN A PERIOD OF
ABOUT 15 SECONDS.
THEY WANTED TO PUSH AN AGENDA SO
THEY HID EVIDENCE.
>> SO IN THE OBAMA YEARS THEY
HAD RULES OF ENGAGEMENT THAT
ACTUALLY SAID YOU CAN'T SHOOT
UNLESS YOU ARE FIRED UPON.
SO, MAYBE YOU WILL DIE FIRST OR
SOMEBODY GETS INJURED FIRST AND
THEN YOU CAN FIGHT THE WAR?
>> THE BATTLEFIELD WILL LAWYER
WILL COME YOU CAN'T FIRE AND
SHOW HOSTILE INTENT UNTIL YOU
FEEL HOSTILE THREAT.
BUT USUALLY BY THE TIME THAT
HAPPENS YOU ARE BLOWING UP, UP
AND YOU ARE SHOT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN A BOLD
STEP TO END OUT AND WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR IT.
>> Sean: I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS.
IF WE ARE GOING TO DO THIS TO
GUYS THAT WE SENT TO WAR, WE
CAN'T SEND THEM.
>> RIGHT, ABSOLUTELY.
THE WAY I LOOK AT IT, IF YOU ARE
NOT WILLING TO FIGHT THE WAY YOU
NEED TO FIGHT TO WIN, THEN DON'T
SEND THE UNITED STATES MILITARY
COMMENTS ON THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, OR THE CIA.
>> WHAT ABOUT THOSE GUYS IN THE
AIR-CONDITIONED OFFICES THAT
WANT TO JUDGE YOUR OPINION.
WHAT RECOURSE COUNSELOR DOES HE
HAVE.
BECAUSE I WOULD WANT TO SUE A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> I THINK THE BEST THING THAT
COULD HAPPEN IS THAT CONGRESS
TAKE ACTION TO END THESE
SUICIDAL RULES FOREVER SO, THIS
IS PERSONALLY MY SON AS A YOUNG
PARATROOPER IN THE PRESIDENT IS
NOW TAKING ACTION TO SHOW THAT
HE HAS A BOX OF THESE TRIPS.
WE HAVE TO CODIFY IT SO THAT
NEVER AGAIN HAS THIS EVER
HAPPENED.
>> Sean: YOU DON'T SEEM ANGRY.
I WOULD BE VERY ANGRY.
I WOULD BE ONE POSTOP PERSON
THAT LOST SIX YEARS OF MY LIFE.
>> THAT DOESN'T DO ME ANY GOOD.
WHEN SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPENS
YOU GET REALLY GOOD AT MAKING
LEMONADE.
SO THERE IS ONLY ONE WAY TO DEAL
WITH IT AND I JUST -- THAT IS TO
GET PAST IT AND PUT ONE FRONT
FOOT IN FRONT OF THE OTHER.
JANUARY 20TH, 2017, YOU KNOW, MY
LIFE CHANGED FOREVER.
BECAUSE I KNEW I HAD HOPED THAT
DAY AND I KNEW WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP GETTING ELECTED,
I WAS GOING TO GO HOME.
IT TOOK A LITTLE WHILE BUT HE'S
A BUSY MAN AND BEING ATTACKED
FROM ALL SIDES, EVEN FROM OUR
OWN SIDES.
>> I FOLLOWED YOUR CASE FOR SIX
YEARS AND I MENTIONED IT TO MANY
PEOPLE INCLUDING THE PRESIDENT.
IN AN INTERVIEW.
ANYWAY, WE ARE GLAD YOU ARE HOM
HOME.
>> I APPRECIATE IT.
>> Sean: THE COUNTRY OWES YOU
AN APOLOGY.
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT AN APOLOGY,
I JUST WANT TO FIX IT.
>> I WANT ONE FOR YOU, YOU
DESERVE IT.
AND IT'S HAPPENED TO OTHER
PEOPLE, TOO.
>> IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE
THAT WE ARE WILLING TO GO OVER
THERE AND DROP BOMBS WITH DRONES
AND IN YEMEN AND THINGS LIKE
THAT, EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WHEN YOU HAVE AN INFANTRY MAN ON
THE GROUND MAKING IMPOSSIBLE
DECISIONS, WE SEND THEM TO
PRISON BECAUSE OF WHAT, SOME